[Music]
in dumb criminal news are they ever
smart submitted by mrs. steal your man
yeah she's already married she's still
gonna steal your mouth what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] never satisfied a man who was
allegedly hiding drugs in his but also
accidentally shot himself in the balls
so did he go BAM and then all the drugs
came out of his blood like I actually
never had anything in my ass but I do
want to try it try it just as just so I
can relate to these guys and know what
it feels like what so you can hear some
text you don't have to really if you
like I get enough visuals from just the
pictures just say you want a big
spearmint I'm gonna little gay [ __ ]
front yeah you've gotta hide stuff how
about gangster [ __ ] yeah oh like
something like jail [ __ ] and there's
like when you're at prison and you get
your dick sucked that doesn't mean you
get drugs hide drugs in the pot neutral
neutral grounds getting your dick sucked
in prison by the other guy does not mean
you're gay what does it mean huh what it
means is you're looking for a good time
he means you're bored babies are born
out of your [ __ ] mind that's all that
it is do you have a long sentence that's
right
Prison dick that's all yep so this story
here she don't know this convicted felon
13-time convicted felon 13 times
what are you into three times and then
it's life what state is it like a 13
limit I don't think it means no I think
we're getting strikes mixed up with
counts good get multiple counts right
convicted for multiple counts on a crime
yeah maybe that's it it's not like he
was in court 13 times and then censored
you know he he probably committed 13
felonies or something like he stole 13
dollars 13 is like they stack up crimes
yeah and then for each thing that
Breaking and Entering
and then larceny and then you were armed
or whatever and everyone did it yeah
yeah no this guy this takes place in
Washington State by the way and Kashmir
and so this dude that's a cholo that
wears Patagonia yeah so this dude he
accidentally shot himself in the
genitals in his apartment and by the way
he's 27 so he had a pistol tucked into
his front pocket and then that's when
the gun destroyed her and it sent the
bullet through his testicles in his side
that's God's work right there cuz he's
like you're too stupid you should not
have any more kids I know right so then
instead of heading directly to the
hospital he told his girlfriend to first
strive to the park where he gave the gun
to a friend so then that's when he went
to the hospital and then as doctors
performed surgery we could eat [ __ ] in
his ass a balloon of marijuana slipped
out of his water you don't even have to
do with we've got a balloon of tums in
his ass sweet he was trying to go to
jail
yeah yeah he was trying to go to jail so
the she was trying to sell the weed in
jail oh so he shot his balls I know the
really light well I mean people do crazy
[ __ ] to get himself healthy yet I think
that was a complete accident but he's
trying to go and okay so like they the
reason why he has just weed in his ass
is he's intentionally trying to go in
there to sell drugs inside jail Oh does
he
cuz he already knows he's gonna go to
jail I didn't accident yeah but then
what about the the fact that he didn't
want to have the possession of a firearm
well he was just want to enjoy that that
was an accident that long yeah yeah yeah
so there's he's not trying to do a
couple months rather than a couple years
cuz I had it like a like I had a
co-worker that was like when he was down
in now he said that he knew they all
know like the average time you would
spend for what charge or whatever and
then he would stuff his but with drugs
he would go out
I'd shoot the gun and then he would call
the cops on himself as an anonymous tip
and then they would catch him with the
gun or whatever and then he would go and
he knows that's about like six months or
something but don't they check your but
when you get arrested they do they do
but not thoroughly I guess cuz it still
gets through yeah then he says like you
just sit there and you would sell weed
and then they put money in your accounts
and they do all this stuff and then you
live good cuz you get fed you're saving
money yeah it's better than being on the
outside you can't pay rent you can't pay
your food you don't know what to do yeah
he gets rid of the gun what's the charge
do you think he's trying to seek ya like
cuz would it be this is in California
right no Washington Washington they have
different rules but weed is pretty much
legal now so that's for anyone having
both a weed like balloon in their
[ __ ] that means they're trying to
sell it in jail okay
so then that's so that's when he's
getting surgery when marijuana slips out
so detectives were notified it slipped
out
I knew that yeah we were urged this they
searched his car and found a bag of meth
inside a pair of blood same jeans that
he's taken off before going to the
hospital I think he [ __ ] up the bush
thing his clothes put in his ass the
method is asked and he forgot he put the
reasonable in his eye after that
happened detectives didn't arrest him at
the hospital but instead issued a and a
rest warrant on suspicion of
second-degree felon in possession of a
firearm and unlawful possession of meth
and so he turned himself in two days
later and that's when detectives told
him that he tends to store marijuana in
his ass so during a strip search another
born of marijuana came out of his ass
and then so that's when he was arrested
in charged with possession of a
controlled substance in a Correctional
Facility he needs to practice his kegels
so he's been caught before trying to
smuggle in weed into jail no from from
him
having the weed come out of his ass
during surgery that's when the detective
says pain he tends to do this [ __ ] and
then he did it again he did it again
yeah and then from jail he made multiple
calls to his girlfriend asking her not
to cooperate with the investigators who
were listening in on the calls so bad
and so they charged him with four counts
of tampering with a witness yeah
so now not laughs if you're one of those
investigators I'm just listening with
the [ __ ] tapes rolling here they
would the funny thing is I bet you
they're not even recording him he's
literally he's literally making a phone
call with a cop right behind him they're
just like right behind him like this
what are you doing okay I bet the cop is
on the other line just watching him like
they're both on the phone this is like
doing like this okay I'm not being
recorded right now [ __ ] but well I'll
show you a photo of them if you're
trying to give that accent
well then ain't a Mexican hey he could
be hey yeah we should have known that
what he looks like he looks like a meth
guy that is the craziest bowl cut I've
ever seen with the mullet why does he
look like he has a mouthful of bubble
gum
did he hide the other weed in his budget
full of weed every part of them
well yeah so now the three incidences
incidents are being tried in Superior
Court a threesome pretty smart
okay he'll get a good deal it's too
funny I feel like being a detective is
easy just from all the news that we get
all you got to do is just go all right
that's what he did and that's what
they're just laid out information yeah
he's got a just right note you gotta do
the paperwork I know you don't gotta
actually go in his ass like it fell out
all right cool I know so you're being
held on a 110 thousand dollar bit well
that's a lot it's better get better get
to sellin it's a combined its Washington
State
no back that ass up that's crazy
you know what's crazy is how freakin we
can just walk into a store and buy weed
now even if you're 20 over 21 no one
told him that that was a thing like ever
I know in his life it even for the rest
of his life just hides weed angry
they're like stop putting legal
substances in your human squirrel I say
[ __ ] you don't have to do it's legal
he's like you ain't gonna get me back oh
yeah you're trying to get me yeah who
needs legal dude it's stayin out there
he's going through processing and he
bends over and his balloon just comes
out of his hole like he's like we're
stopping for sure no ambition yeah it's
like Peter you really got to stop this
stuff mean you'd have to hold stuff
namath camera mode
Cameron closed there's a really white
name why does it gets huh weed booty cam
three firstly Killa cam three first
names yeah how old is he
2700 so how long has you been dude he
probably like increased the ask capacity
over there you got to stretch it out
yeah yeah it's like reverse kegels it's
like what if there's a community of
people talk about that [ __ ] they're like
how many Ounces you up to now like they
got a forum on - yeah I wonder how much
you could sell weed for in prison I
don't know I know everything is like
maybe it's cheaper if it was up your ass
longer even cigarettes is how expensive
oh yeah it's so hot I wonder if it's
like difficult to smoke weed in prison
cuz you could smell it right yeah so we
had a big boy on our podcast a big ass
cholo dude and he was saying like even
with like cigarettes and stuff there's a
certain way you hold it where you hide
the cherry so a lot of people they come
out at jolly smoke like this
this cuz they're holding it so when
they're on the yard you can't see the
cherry see no weight compare because
they're from so far away and then
especially at night
so you don't want to see that glowing
red Dean there's just so many ways he's
explaining like
huh at night use certain times to go to
the yard and there's even different ways
of flushing the toilet like there's so
many like things that it is too much
work to smoke a cigarette did they get
no enjoyment they got to get something
yeah I just do crossword puzzles all day
they get really good at drawing women
there's a guy hiding that in his ass for
you but uh the crossword puzzle book and
you let me tell you something this is
actually worth ten times more than the
weed it's really hard the entire book
for you
[Music]